hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
coverage of e3 2019 I'm magma Hardy here
with Michael hi I'm hi
and we also have Rainbow six siege as
creative director Laroy at the Nassau
yes exactly I like Matt many times more
I'm a big fan of the game we've been
covering it
phantom site the newest update expansion
to Rainbow six siege the ongoing hero
tactical shooter just released two days
ago yesterday and it happens every year
there's always an expansion during e3
and you have to make me wait to play it
yes thanks yeah so tell me about it for
those who might not be maybe if they've
been lapsed on siege or just didn't see
the Ubisoft conference tell me about
start with the operators what what are
the two operators so we are bringing
into the game like Walden and not and
all this season you know it's about this
the magic of phantom sight but kind of
hide and seek
it's play with vision we have Wadden
that was the first time we'll be able to
activate gadgets that allow him to see
smoke because as you know in this game
smoke is part of the strategy of the
attacker and the well depend on were
lacking of you know active tool to to
pintado strategy so he can flip through
smoke and on the other side we have not
that is able you know to get invisible
through camera or any kind of electronic
device as a bulletproof camera by Jerry
can maestro 2x so since now the
defending team has a lot of you know
rely on a lot of observation Tula having
those operators as the ability you know
to to like vanish from those point of
view it's super strong because it's you
to have character this tells gameplay
this tells feeling and the kind of a
portion flow clunk on the side was there
like a specific theme you were trying to
go forward with these two operators with
phantom sight like I know sometimes
there's like a theme to it there's like
I know with white noise it was very much
about Hell right with phantom sight was
there kind of a thematic tie with this
exactly and it's not something that we
decided at the beginning of the season
you're like it's a pee accident because
every time we try to see what fits the
best for each side and and sometimes
like white noise and like this season we
have kind of gadgets are altering each
other because yes now what you know that
oxygen smoke out about accretion but now
walden can see through smoke and on the
opposite we have not
that now is able to become invisible so
every single item as you know sir the
view perception and it's it's a
variation around this and what you
squeeze that since it's a national game
lag and play are kind of texts different
texts of what it means to be seen or
unseen the planning of if you wanna take
care of a defender and actually we're
seeing some footage right now ideas of
the rewired rework for cafe to stay up
yes it's something that we have super
abroad and super happy likes to you know
like we work a warm up based on the
community feedback Pro League feedback
is posted back to you know fix our map
and try to bring them at a level of
balancing well as a different as an
attacker you have equal equal chances of
winning and having like as many a bomb
site balance as possible and it's funny
we were talking earlier you also are
adding a newcomer playlist to the
schedule we've been we've had destiny to
up here we've had warframe we've had a
lot of these games that are like ongoing
services kind of as that buzzword and
it's always interesting how do you get
how do you introduce new players to this
game that in Rainbow six siege cases
been out almost four years now how do
you introduce players to a very in-depth
game after it's already been like
learned by so many people and the
newcomers playlist seems like yes it's a
it's a first step because keep in mind
that for us it's a never-ending
initiative expect with the seasons to
come to see us like continue to improve
and release feature about you know
newcomers that will help us the
onboarding of this game the newcomer
players in itself is that we're trying
to tackle one of the most difficult
aspects that there is in this game that
we had you know a lot of studio and data
that forty percent of the difficulty
that are pressing by players come from
the knowledge of the map there is so
many map that are some with you know
like with descriptions are so many
possibility that when you start this
game you're overwhelmed by I know like a
number of things that you need to learn
to be able to master this map so the
newcomer place is about only free map
you know like and when you're going to
enter this place you are going to play
over and over again till three map that
are not especially let's say easy map
that if that are more like
balanced
that will bring you to the like a
quicker to the main game to the manor
you know where of how this game is
playing of in terms of attack and
defense yeah for well when you bring in
new operators into Rainbow six siege I
mean obviously you want to do something
that's you know drastically different
that shakes up the game but in year four
have bringing in two new operators like
how challenging is it to make something
that's both balanced with every other
operator but also distinct distinctively
new for the game it's always something
that is a it's a it's complicated and
actually that is like to me to a two
type of change either you are creating
though you're playing with a system that
is already existing in the game and
you're just trying to find an
alternative or version like typically
the Walden gameplay that could be a you
know like it's a it's an answer of the
already existing glass or bulletproof
camera gameplay the ability to sit for
smoke so this one is much easier in
terms of of balance and game design
because you're relying on something that
already exists where you have data you
have a feedback so it's guys it's my job
but when you create like very a new type
of gameplay like for example I don't
know like but not not even onesie but
not maybe for example
it's a bit more difficult and that's why
we have a lot of poor PlayStation we
have a lot of we are inviting player
into our studio we have description with
them like doing the word prediction
process like we met we need them a
different stage early prototype you know
like something more advanced before the
end of realization and stuff like that
and and and and what I mean it's a and
at some point you have to make a leap of
faith because with the hustle have some
things that is a bit you know like
CoreLogic in terms of power ballads huh
but bring something fresh and new and
since we all that game we we always have
opportunity you know to to go back on
them walk them you know refine them when
million of player are playing them and
maybe find some flows that we were not
able to work but at least we are not you
know studying into the always a mechanic
we know that we need to bring every time
fresh ID fresh core gameplay so we keep
you know like the player but we renew
and refresh experience
the time we can't just you know that we
should be trying to have something stole
and being perfectly balanced might you
know put us in a place where the game is
actually studying and we don't want that
so sometimes yes we are going to take
Chris and we are going to continue
spoiler alert and we are going to cut
into that because we feel like it it's
worth because anyway we have like
Shannon and committee attention to act
on it later on and in the most extreme
case we have also accounting system you
know with like where we took a lion when
we are like it was so problematic
we had to be working and it took time so
we know that we have the opportunity to
even put it on the site for Polly for
example you're also reworking a ranked
playlist Louis matchmaking etc can you
talk about that and that's what the aim
is that rework the team like you know
like I was about this running gag on
this project with a honk Beta Beta tag
and first this season is a season where
we are tackling a lot of things that we
felt we're missing two other core
experience of honk and be able to say
like okay we are happy we are we have
the set of the wrong so not only we are
bringing the pick and ban models at
first that is super important and part
of how you should play this game on on a
competitive level we are changing also
our matchmaking system and matchmaking
rules to ensure like more fairness and
to to ensure like more interesting
matches whatever I do Ravel from
corporate today Amanda and also what you
need to keep in mind is that it's when
we start to work on the feature now we
have changed our prediction process that
if you are going to support it for the
long run that mean expect also on the
increment season a lot of feature on
improvement and it's always an ongoing
process when we start something same for
newcomers and for every feature that we
are doing to again that we are going to
ship off them and develop them even
further so it just the first milestones
the first big step of rent in two
editions of liquor ban ReWalk of the of
the wrong system enter what we call the
honk exposition where you know like you
have now dedicated tab where you you
have the old exposure time we change the
map pool we are focusing on bomb only no
more secure and offstage when I'm trying
to be closer to competitive but still
with the next rounds that is got sewer
and accessible to all
team player there is no such thing like
as a for example long diffuse of time or
absence removal of HUD and stuff like
that it seems like a paradox you almost
have to increase the you know that you
have to increase the depth of the game
but at the same time you have to make
sure it seems somewhat accessible to
everyone new people or like or even like
a lapsed player who wants to come back
in it seems like a paradox but you guys
seem to nail it pretty well the thing is
that we believe that the best way to
play siege is to play in ranked with a
spread of five men and so every feature
that weapons again are trying to you
know fernell you to this experience it's
not always possible just because
sometimes you don't have friends or you
don't have time to play around because
it's a commitment but the more you will
see the future with the new release of
feature in season the more you will see
that we are trying to bring you to this
experience because this is what we
believe the game shines a must and
you've the number that people stuck to
about a couple years ago you said you
know you know there's a quote where you
said we want to eventually get to a
hundred operators is that still the it's
still it's still like you know the
original ending point and it's for sure
some things that we are going to reach
at some point and you can already see
that for the season for example when you
look at Sophia October you can
anticipate what's going on on the new
season because you will see that we
reach the maximum so some things will
happen in season three - under that and
and we probably will continue also like
even if we reach 100 operator we might
probably continue to release operator it
is that we believe that we need to be as
fast as put it we need to reach as fast
as possible so 100 because this is where
we believe that there will be enough
death enough opportunity enough
variation in term of open data online
herbs that you can play on map to ensure
infinite you know like a gameplay loop
infinite like never half drives us and
matches and maybe we will probably I
don't know like maybe a decrease the
rate of release go better but for sure I
think operator into this game is always
fun always importance of there will
always be new operator
it just might threaten so numbers I'm a
challenger in the far future
does the team ever get overwhelmed
though when you say you want to have a
hundred operators because you're
throwing in more variables and with a
game as sensitive as Rainbow six siege
in terms of balance
do you ever be like okay we're gonna get
to 100 operators but how are we going to
handle that because things constantly
change when you attack these places and
different things and yes ever changing
Maps you ought to tell you right and
it's a it's something that we struggle a
lot the first year also right because we
are also learning so process and you
know like okay how it is to make a
competitive game that lasts forever and
and now we really change our approach
you could see if you look back on season
that every time we were adding an
operator we were adding it like like
like if there were no tomorrow you know
like it was his own system and it owns
feature and then we are moving to
another player trying to sing something
new and never think about the war system
in itself now we have changed this
approach we're trying to have a more
rational more systemic approach and you
will see like all dr. Otto at some point
will be will apps the rework and there
are even to be to fit in this systemic
alab part and now when we release an
open-cell what you want to do that we
want to release like want to be we want
them to be part of a system you know
like so they are not it's just not about
the operators the power balance and the
problem well it's not about the power to
itself is about okay how does it bring
something you in an already existing
system or how does it bring a new system
where there will be also operator
interacting with him on the system not
being an system in itself because this
is where it's become very hard to
balance because if I'm the only one
doing something very important typically
preaching are bunching meta by chain how
do we balance that because you need this
operator you can't even have a freaking
band system in those kind of that why
you know in first yeah we can ban was
not a thing because okay what if people
mantle meet up end of the game no
competition so we knew that we had to
transform the way we are designing
operator and have a more systemic
approach and this is like this year is
starting really like also part of that
we will we we know is this year will
have this approach is even when we will
release want that feel like it's a new
system it's probably because we have
already in mind prototype and also
operators that will come that will play
with what this okay I'll bring it again
I know you can't probably can tell too
into specifics well so so with Ramos
explorin team that's a completely
separate game it's a completely separate
team the whole seeds team is still here
it's gonna keep making seeds till 100
operators but it's curious to see Ella
show up in the trailer for a totally
different game what's it like to see
like like I don't again I don't know if
it's a spinoff I don't know it's like a
separate game but I'm curious what's it
like to see these characters that you've
created kind of branching off into their
own things but as we said it's boss it's
a it's a I seem like the boss was a dev
team of CG and the player of siege it's
a it's very likely I'll say like it's a
good news and especially for the dev
team it's a some pride and some
happiness because it's really nice to
see like a fully dedicate know a very
different dedicated team amongst well
you know loving so much Siege and
especially what we did with the outbreak
event wanted to take that you know like
and develop it further like I mean it's
a no it's great
most positive team for Earth like
because it's like okay people look what
we've done and also for Supriya because
it's good to have you know more rainbow
out there so I'm actually I'm as excited
as you I think to to to know more about
this game awesome all right anything
else before we close out I mean like go
life go plays the new season we see like
there is a ton of other features that we
didn't have time to discuss like the
reverse 20 failure for example to try to
under as a toxicity a lot of new content
and yes like I think this one will be
like one of the most important season we
had like before at least this year
awesome Laroy earthen ass off as always
thank you so much for coming on Nagamani
me and all of you at home we will be
right back after the short break to talk
about Final Fantasy 14 storm bringers
see you then
[Applause]
you
[Applause]